[Applause]
but who else is oppressed it's the
climate people because they need climate
Justice and this is this is really the
video of the day this is so spectacular
so Greta Thunder who is a climate ho
okay
she she uh she's given a speech about
climate that's what she does but you
know in this intersectional cacophony of
insanity she has now combin this with
oppression and they've combined this
with Gaza and she's a big fan of Hamas
because you know Hamas loves taking
water pipes chopping up and turning them
into Rockets that's very sound for the
environment anyway she's giving a speech
at a big climate conference and she
starts going on and on about occupied
land and then some guy gets on stage to
basically tell her lady we're supposed
to be talking about the climate and
watch them fight and it's just like have
at it like this is Mortal Kombat Finish
him go people on the front lines of the
climate crisis have been experiencing
the firstand consequences of it for
decades now and they have been sounding
the alarm but but we have not been
listening the people in power have not
been listening I come here for a climate
demonstration not a political
[Applause]
view this
is calm
[Applause]
down calm
down have at it like Let Them Fight you
know God Godzilla vers King Kong Let
them fight these people like she's just
she's so profoundly awful we knew she
was profoundly awful this entire time
she's a globalist she's a communist
whatever you want to call her but she
gets up there they want to hear about
climate change and by the way guys the
climate's not coming for you everyone
settle down you're going to be okay
Barack Obama knows it that's why he has
a 30 acre estate on Mar's Vineyard on
the water right there it's going to be
just fine don't you worry about that
Bill Gates what does he have a $50
million house right off Seattle right on
the water don't worry about them guys
John Cary flying private planes all over
the Earth to make sure that you can't
fly
planes and then the guy gets up there
lady what are you talking about what
does this have to do with Hamas and
occupied land and then they drag him off
the stage you people this is inter love
you love
you